il n'est que fait justin trudeau sur un
plateau de télé réalité en afghanistan
[Musique]
chevelure ondulante sourcils
broussailleux mâchoire anguleuses
d'outiller est il devenu le chanteur il
faut dire qu'avec les nombreux costumes
du premier ministre canadien on ne sait
plus trop où donner de la tête
volonté de faire sourire ou de plaire
lors de ses déplacements à l'étranger
comme ici en inde les différentes
facettes de justin trudeau font souvent
l'objet de moqueries et de railleries et
rouge ou alors faut-il s'étonner de sa
participation à afghane star ce n'est
bien sûr pas justin trudeau
mais avouez que la ressemblance est
frappante
ce sosie s'appelle ça la maaf thoune
c'est un jeune paysan de la province
rurale des rates en afghanistan depuis
toujours il caresse le désir de devenir
une vedette de la chanson
d'où sa participation à afghane star
awards c'est l'équivalent d'american
idol une téléréalité bâti autour de
talents potentiels de la chanson la
version afghane a vu le jour en 2005
quatre ans après la chute du régime des
talibans un régime brutal qui avait
instauré l'interdiction de chanter et
même ordonné de brûler des instruments
de musique
depuis c'est l'une des émissions les
plus populaires du pays sur la chaîne
tholot sur les réseaux sociaux on
compare la physionomie des deux hommes
et même sur le plateau de l'émission la
ressemblance avec le numéro un canadien
ne passe pas inaperçu même si
l'animateur le rebaptise juste un
tournedos à justin tornadoes tôle aux
six nations jusqu'ici ça la maaf thoune
continue de séduire les foules et
poursuit son petit bout de chemin dans
ce concours de popularité
parlant de popularité et de qualité de
chant qui gagnerait entre celui ci vive
le vent vive et celui là à vous de voter
ici frédéric arnould radio-canada à
montréal
khalid